ميلانو دائما
لا اتذكر الان يمكن ان تقلل بصفحات
التاريخ اييي احد نواب مجلس الدوله
كيروسور
لغه الروسيه والثقافه الروسيه واا
فصل
وحدتنا الروحيه والجميع يتجاهلها لماذا
لان غرضهم نفسه فرق تسد لا يريد احد توحد
الشعب الروسي
التفرقه نعم هم مستعدون لقطعه اكثر ولكن
الوحده والقوه لا يريدها احد اعدادا
وسنبقى وسنفعلها هذا ههه
ما الامر هنا قلت امس انه من بدايه كانون
الثاني
الجيش
عفوا
فيه تسريحات جديده
مع ان هذه النظم هي متوسطه المدى ولكن
خصائصها من حيث السرعه
تمنحنا مزايا معينه
فهي انظمه قديمه بما فيه الكفايه
ولا تعملوا كما تعملوا منظومه 300 مثلا
دفاعي
سناخذ هذا في الحسبان ببساطه وسنجد ترياقا
لهذا فمن يفعلونه يفعلون ذلك سدن انها
اطاله النزاع
لها
السؤال بشان العمل العسكريه الخاصه بشكل
تقليدي دائما تقيمون بشكل مختصر نتائج
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي خطوره من
مماطله الاسماء
همم
والغرب 2014
همم قلت هذا مرارا ولكن
هدفنا ليس تاجيج الحرب بل انهاء هذه الحرب
هذا ما نسعى وسنسعى اليه
اما بخصوص
فهذا طبيعيه
لنستمر تفضلوا شكرا جزيلا قناه روسيا
سؤالي باستمرار لهذا الموضوع في الدوائر
الغربيه هناك افكار وخاصه
الناتو بان الموارد التي تقدم الغرب
لاوكرانيا ليست غير محدوده وهناك الكثير
من الخبراء يقولون بان الموارد الروسيه
ايضا تنتهي وهذه هي الصواريخ الاخيره همم
هذا
الخطاب مشهور ومع ذلك همم يمكن همم مجمع
العسكري الروسي ان يقدم احتياطي اللازم
وكذلك انتاج العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
اعتقد ان موارد الدول الغربيه الاستنفاد
الموضوع انه اوكرانيا يتصل اليها اسلحه من
دول
الاتحاد السوفيتي الغربيه
7 7
والتصليح وهي قضيه ليست سهله
ثانيا هناك مسائل تتعلق بامكانيات
المجمع الصناعي العسكري للدول الغربيه
الاستاذ
وتطوير نظام جديد انها عمليه مديده وصعبه
كل هذا في الحسبان
كل ما موجود وما بقي في مخازينه وما
يستطيعون انتاجه وفي اي ظرف زمني وكيف
يمكن ان يدربه
طبعا
مثلا همم
لكن الفرق
كما قلت امس في اجتماع وزاره الدفاع لن
يكون هذا على حساب
القطاعات الاقتصاديه الاخرى
بكل الاحوال يجب ان نؤمن
احتياجات جيشنا
وبخلاف صناعه اوكرانيا
وصلوا لنفسه هذا
فرصه للحل الدبلوماسي للازمه في اوكرانيا
بشكل من الاشكال
بمفاوضات على المسار الدبلوماسيه ولم نرفض
هذا يوما لانها قياده اوكرانيا
تفضلوا السيد فاليري
وكاله بيستي اف ام فخامه الرئيس
الابطال
هناك في الصاله
الاوسمه ايضا هناك قائمه بعد عدد كبير من
الابطال
مرتبط يرتبط بالخسائر
والجروح وما اليه اليه كقاعده
انهم اقوى الناس انهم في المقدمه
وطبعا هم ابطال فقلت هذا مرارا
انها قناعه الشخصيه
الان في هذه الساعه الصاله في الكريملين
فوقنا شمسنا الصناعيه
جميل اما الشباب
نتحدث
[موسيقى]
الاحذيه والاسلحه
وهم تحت القصف طبعا جميعهم ابطال انه عمل
صعب يرتبط بالخطر على الصحه والحياه ولكن
بينهم
بافعال مميزه
الشخصيه
طبعا
لمجتمعنا
المستقبل هؤلاء الناس
يقونا
روح الشعب
وبعضهم الاخر لا نعرفهم ولم يسمهم بالاسم
لكننا سنفعل بكل تاكيد
الرئيس
تكون في العام القادم هل يمكن ان تبقى
الاقتصاد الروسي همم
اضافه الى ذلك تم الحديث سابقا عن همم
الاعمال والبزنس ولكن في هذا العام لم يتم
الحديث عن ذلك
يتعلق بالتمويل اضافه الى ذلك همم
بالوعود بشان المساعدات الاجتماعيه هل
ستنفذ له
بخصوص الاقتصاد تطرقت لهذا الموضوع ولكن
ربما يجب ان اضيف الى هذا ان انهيار
الاقتصاد لم يقع نعم هناك انخفاض واكرر
مره اخرى البعض كان يامل ان همم التقلص
عندنا سيكون نحو 20% او 25% او اكثر همم
التقلص موجود
او 25 بالاثنين فاصل خمسه بالمئه
التضخم كما قلت
وهو من اهم المؤشرات
اثني عشر بالمئه
من بلاد الاخرى بما في ذلك بلاد مجموعه
العشرين
طبعا التضخم
من الدول الاخرى وفي السنه القادمه كما
ذكرنا يكمل نكيف بيراميدز
الاقتصاد في الربع الاول سنسعه الى مؤشرات
نحو اربعه خمسه بالمئه وهي نزهه جيده
بخلاف عدد من دول اخرى في العشرين
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه فاصل ثمانيه